sting loyauté de l'amour du ciel keller
entre donc quoi ils sortent vraiment
sous la douce c'est pas vrai maman je
tai chi nois des jo tu mets ton bonnet
tu viens juste d'avoir un rhume elles
sont où vos soeurs je me trouve nulle
part
anna joy j'ai fouillé toute la maison et
sont pas là bas il y avait un camping
car et l3 côté il y avait quelqu'un
dedans je suis l'inspecteur l'eau qui
vous avez des enfants et specter
je vais retrouver vos filles
emma enlève tout
chez ces gamines quelque part alex je
sais que takashi seguer me dresse est en
garde à vue jusqu'à ce qu'on retrouve ma
fille la garde à vue de 48 heures se
termine demain sociaux l'inculte bien
récupérer quelque chose
ce garçon n'a jamais causé moins de
problèmes de tout
aucune trace dans ce truc j'ai fouillé
la forêt près de repos c'est aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que t'en as fait ça fait six
jours et chaque matin elle doit se
demander pourquoi je suis pas là tu nous
avais dit tu pourrais nous protéger de
tout pourquoi vous ne cherchez pas mari
alex